l'histoire de trêve c'est avant tout une
histoire de famille très vite issu d'un
croisement imaginé par alec head le père
de christiane dans son haras du quesnay
près de deauville
bref c'est mon père qui l'a conçu
puisque il a envoyé sa mère à motivateur
c'est la dernier un monstre est plus
après le pouvoir sa mère était très
bonne mais s'était accidenté sa mère a
couru une fois il a gagné et motivateur
lui il a gagné le derby d'epsom c'était
un très grand cheval à son époque quand
il était en course
maintenant vous savez les grands
champions les grandes championnes savait
pas toujours le meilleur cheval il n'y a
rien d'écrit
dans la famille head la passion du
cheval s'est transmise de génération en
génération
à 91 ans le patriarche alec est toujours
tel qu'en lui même une grande figure de
l'élevage et des courses ancien jockey
ancien entraîneur et éleveur de pur sang
il tient sa passion pour les chevaux de
son père will i ici portant un chapeau
et il l'a transmise tout naturellement à
ses aînés freddy et cricket avant même
qu'ils ne sachent marché bas ils sont
presque né leur box alors quand on est
dans un box s'est dirigé vers autre
chose
vous êtes fière d'elle aujourd'hui alors
je suis fier d'elle il ya longtemps que
je suis fier d'elle parce qu'aujourd'hui
je me souviens très bien quand j'étais
tout petit
peut-être toujours fourré dans la coure
toujours avec lui et d'aller voir les
chevaux et ça c'était c'était ma passion
mon grand père est un grand
professionnel aussi et donc mon grand
père me disait toujours tu vas voir les
chevaux je pouvais pas les faire sortir
j'avais 10 ans mais je regardais tous
les chevaux qui étaient sortis que les
autres clients regarder et puis je
faisais des annotations et ensuite
j'allais le voir et lui m'emmenait avec
lui pour m'expliquer ce que j'avais vu
ou pas vue et mon père faisait la même
chose
cricket recevait tous les jours
l'ancêtre du pari turf dans son
pensionnat anglais poursuivre le travail
de son père elle a tout naturellement
voulu devenir entraîneur très jeune mais
dans les années 60 70
cela ne ce feu
c'est pas mon père me disait tout le
temps va écoute quand tu seras plus
grande si tu veux tu épousera un
entraîneur puis tu pourras être à ses
côtés l'aider voilà dans ses tâches mais
moi ça ça ne satisfaisait pas du tout et
moi j'ai toujours eu dans le fond de ma
pensée et envie de devenir entraîneur un
jour et c'est grâce à son père qu'elle
s'installe en 77 ans 78 30 ans il gagne
sa première course de groupe 1
un an plus tard elle rafle son premier
rang de triomphe avec three troïkas zh
déjà une histoire de famille
la jument dont papa l'a acheté elle est
revenue en france c'est moi qui l'ait
prise à l'entraînement donc il m'a
laissé à préparer mon frère était choqué
à l'époque c'est lui qui la monte et
c'était la soul et kazakh de maman
c'était vraiment une affaire de feuilles
la famille le clan c'est très important
chez les aides cricket dit qu'elle n'a
rien inventé qu'elle a été élevé comme
ça son rapport à ces chevaux à ses
salariés ses propriétaires aux
supporteurs et à la presse elle l'a
héritée de ses parents
c'est pour cela qu'elle a tant donné
avant le troisième arc de triomphe de
trêve devenue un phénomène médiatique
sans précédent dans le monde du galop
elle l'a fait aussi bien sûr pour son
cheval trêve qui lui a tant donné
alors trêve sera dans ma carrière le
cheval de ma vie ça c'est sûr c'est sûr